the European Union has initialed
ambitious Accords on closer ties with
Georgia and Moldova at the Eastern
Partnership summit in Lithuania the to
put their initials on Association
agreements in the capital Vilnius while
Azerbaijan signed an agreement that will
ease the issue of visas last minute
efforts to encourage Ukraine to sign an
association agreement and a deep and
comprehensive free-trade area pact that
could have boosted its economy did not
bear fruit the offer of signing the most
ambitious agreement the European Union
has ever offered to a non-member state
is still on the table we stand ready to
sign with Ukraine once the benchmarks
put forward by the European Union are
met we have to set aside short-term
considerations and we have to overcome
pressure from abroad this is a time of
courage this is a time of decisions for
Ukraine to sign it would have had to
meet benchmarks in three areas the
government must ensure that elections
respect international standards address
the issue of selective justice and make
sure it doesn't happen again and
implement business reforms ahead of the
summit EU leaders voiced concern that
Russia had pressured Ukraine not to sign
the Eastern Partnership helps the EU to
strengthen cooperation and trade with
six countries Armenia Azerbaijan Georgia
Moldova Belarus and Ukraine Georgia and
Moldova could sign their association
agreements in a year